thank you so thank you for joining and I
will talk about a work that is called
fully secured are to be based in fiction
what you see at one lwe alright so let
me start with what attribute based
encryption is so we consider a public
key encryption system and normally in
standard public key encryption that so
there is a public key with which you can
encrypt the message and then there is a
secret key and only the person that
holds the secret key can encrypt it can
tikrit ciphertext and we consider a
setting that users and potentially give
them different permissions to decrypt a
ciphertext so the way that it is model
this is follow so we assume an authority
so that already has a master secret
system and in addition it is possible to
take this master secret key and then to
delegate permissions and generate what
we call constraint cheats so now the
question is how we formalize the
permissions of each key or I would
determine the ciphertext
which keys are allowed to decrypt so
there are two doing options and here
will consider the ciphertext policy
notion so here is so every every secret
key is associated with some unique
identity which called an attribute of
the key so it can be any known any
number in some large space to encrypt
the message then we specify some
function which we call the policy and
this F should specify which attributes
are allowed to decrypt the message so
this function f it it takes about
written it out
either zero one which determines whether
a key respective to this attribute
should be able to
so now system then we can we can measure
its quality or its expressiveness
according to a few different properties
and in this talk I will focus on two
main properties so the first one will be
the kind of security guarantee that we
get so we have either full security or
selective security and in the next slide
in the next few slides I will explain in
more detail what are the differences and
in addition to other important important
property is the class of supported
policies that we can have in the system
so we want is we want this to be as
expressive as possible so we can have
the complex access it is mostly
interesting to consider the case where
the attribute space is exponentially
large because if we have small number of
possible attributes then it's actually
impossible to have attribute based
encryption from any standard public
encryption simply by using combinatorial
techniques of multiple instances of
public encryption so we always assume
that attribute spaces is of size 2 to
the N okay and another important
definition identity based encryption so
actually identity based encryption was
defined before actually based in fiction
but in this talk I want to think of it
as a special case of a PE so in identity
based encryption still there are
multiple multiple keys in the system but
now whenever we encrypt the message we
need to specify this specific specific a
that should be allowed to do so
it's like attribute based encryption but
where we only support access policies
that are just
that only accept the single attributes
okay so now let me explain in more
details in the difference between okay
so that intuitively does the security
notion that you want to have is that if
a user has a secret key for some
acrobatics Denis is only allowed to
defeat ciphertext for policies that
support lease attributes so now let's
try to formalize this so to look at the
entire attribute space and now for a
given policy f we can we can divide this
attribute space to two to two different
types of attributes so I use the gray
color to denote attributes that are
authorized in the white text and now for
this specific F we want to say that if
an adversary only has kids left or not
allowed shouldn't learn anything about
the message so we assume an adversary
that can have and I didn't but you
should only have polynomial in many
cases and then thinking that we would
like to have is that if he only has this
kind of set of keys then it should be
hard for him to the creep ciphertext so
the way to say this is by using a
security game between between the
Challenger we had which has the full
depiction permissions and the adversary
so the adversary gets to see the public
key of the scheme and then he can query
for decryption keys so that face he can
make multiple queries and each search
query he would send and actually fix and
then
the Challenger should generate the
respective g40 such boutiques and return
it to the adversary and then at some
point there will be the challenge faced
or the adversary sensical ECF and then
the Challenger should generate the
psychic txt expecting to deserve so she
should encrypt either a zero and now the
adversary can make additional key
queries after the after the challenge
phase just didn't write it on the slide
to save space and what you can see you
can't do that okay so compete see why it
should be hard to achieve this kind of
security to have any scheme that can be
proved so to have computational security
based on some computationally hard
problem so we need to show a reduction
will show reduction detects an adversary
that can win in this security can use it
in order to solve a computationally hard
problem thank you yes
so we restrict the search to only query
for for kids for us for actions that are
not authorized by the by the policy
because otherwise she's allowed to do
honestly was the relationship between F
and the ciphertext for F define so in
the previous slide we did this in the
definition slide I wrote here that's the
during encryption you should provide and
fiction algorithm with the policy F and
then the ciphertext is generated with
respect to that policy does the encoding
of the adversaries F and
to be efficient so that could be a
property of the scheme but because we
want everything to run in polynomial
time and then fiction algorithm takes
takes F then the description should be
efficient yeah if I get the question
correctly okay okay so to why it should
be hard to get this kind of security so
we want to we would like to show a
reduction from the adversary that that
has some advantage in to solve the
community hard problem so in more detail
we need to construct the text as input
an instance of the computationally hard
problem and now we have to interact with
the adversary in order to to use this
power so in more detail let's see what
are the exact what is the exact
information that we have to provide to
the adversary so first we need to give
in the public key then we should be able
to answer all the key queries so
whenever an adversary asks for a key for
some X that is in the know not a right
space the word should we should be able
to simulate a proper key for that
attribute and eventually in the in in
the challenge phase we we have to
simulate the ciphertext so we get F and
then we need to provide adversary with
with the Challenger ciphertext and the
thing that should be hard for the
adversary in the game is distinguish
whether this is an encryption of 0 or 1
so we have to use the capability of the
adversary to do this to distinguish
between those two cases so it means that
we need to have the property in the
simulator that if it is possible to
decrypt the ciphertext
with encryption of zero then
disadvantage should be translated to an
advantage in solving the computationally
hard problem okay so we have to come up
with this kind of a simulator so let's
see why why it's inherently hard okay so
let's see what is the neighbor proach we
need to be to be able to answer any
possible query any query so assume that
we have a simulator that can simulate
kids for all possible attributes in the
system because we we don't know in
advance which which is the adversary
will ask for so it would allow us to but
I claim that it cannot satisfy the third
property in the third requirement of so
if we can simulate keys for all of the
possible attributes then in particular
we can also simulate skills for
authorized attributes and once we select
means for authorized attributes then the
correctness of the scheme we can decrypt
the ciphertext locally and the
deflecting the ciphertext
results in solving the computational
problem is that the simulator can
actually locally solve the
computationally hard problem without
even interacting with the adversary okay
looks like we're okay for now okay so
the conclusion from this discussion is
that is that we should somehow come up
with the simulator that on one hand the
kid simulator is for all the authorized
attributes but cannot simulate keys for
any non authorized attributes and but
the inherent problem with this
requirement is that we don't know what
are the right attributes and what are
the very
tributes up until the challenge phase
because this this partitioning of the
attribute space is determined according
to F and the adversary only sense of the
challenge face what we have to already
generate keys in the keyboard space so
this is why it should be hard to prove
full security or adaptive security so
the first approach can you guess what
the challenge would be that's a good
question so the challenge is a function
so if if you want to support an
expressive function space then the
guessing would be we will have a lot of
security because the space is super
exponentially large so the first
approach to overcome this problem is to
simply have an easier security
definition or a weaker security and this
is collective security and in this
setting we function so the way that it
is translated to the security reduction
is that now we only need to to come up
with a simulator that that also gets FZ
so it gets the D computationally hard
problem but it also gets F and then it
can you can act according to you can
generate the public key in such a way
that later it is only possible to
generate respective kids for them for
the non authorized activities now
it still doesn't make the problem
trivial and you took a lot of effort to
come up with but at least it overcomes
this is a challenge discussed early ok
[Music]
so prior to this work the existing
constructions of a B menu rely on two
types of computationally hard problem
so the first time by linear groups the
second type is I mean computationally
hard problem over well in your groups
and the second type is computationally
hard problems over lattices and more
specifically we and in both of those
things is kind of so first the work
instructions for with selective security
for I B so I remind that IB is a B what
we only need to support the very strict
very restrictive function space where
each function only authorizes a single
attribute so first of all constructions
with selected security and only for for
this point functions later there were
constructions that achieve the full
security but still for this restrictive
function space later they came
constructions that support a larger
class of function so in Bellino groups
it's they both only have selected
security and then there was a large
breaks groups a be for an expressive
function class but simple status as this
question remained open so the what we do
in this work is to is to show a fully
security construction and the function
classical support is is its
so for example the outline in the second
step would be to generalize this this
idea and instead of supporting only IPA
now will support more functions so Bab
but instead of fusing it started PR f mu
nu something that is called a constraint
pair which I would describe later what
it is and eventually since for the
second step to work we need the
constraint we have to satisfy some
special properties then the last step
would be to actually construct special
properties and this is the step where
where we get stuck in we can only
support that easy and affordable us
instead of all serious question is
selective and fool I ve known from non
be by linear assumptions yes there are
constructions from lwe oh you mean from
yes so there is a construction from deah
for IB
what's for a be noticing the wall
[Music]
all right so let me now start
so the the starting point of the of the
fully secure IP from the PRF will be
based on my technique by gently achieved
IP so just to make sure we're on the
same page so we now see there I be so it
means that the cipher texts are also
associated with a single attribute so I
call this X Prime and if we use same
visualization so now the authorized
space is only authorized spaces of the
other attributes and again the adversary
can query for polynomially many kids in
the white area and eventually he sends
the six Prime and gets the challenge a
ciphertext expecting to the six prime
okay so let's see how what's the idea of
Gentry so he defined something that is
called tagging and here is how it works
so instead of using the standard
attribute space now use a slightly
larger and attribute space so we use
something so now we can think of it as a
two dimensional space so each row now
corresponds to an attribute of the
scheme that we eventually want to
achieve but in addition now we have this
additional stress that that will call
the tag so now every time every time we
want to consider an attribute we can
actually then addition the tag team okay
so why is this useful so assume now that
we want to to encrypt the cipher text
for some attribute X so we first
go to the row of six and then we
randomly choose one of the columns and
we generate the cipher text according to
the to the resulting attribute so there
at Vietnam would be the the actual X for
which now we want to generate a
decryption key so decryption keys are
associated so we need to generate
something that is allowed to defeat the
entire row because we don't know on
which the cipher text is going to be so
so so again we randomly choose
efficiency in terms of rows are the XS
and the columns are the XS this case
the okay the the entire metrics is the
attribute space which is equivalent to
the single column that we saw in
previous so an entry corresponds to
scientist and an entry in this table
corresponds to an attribute I want to
start I want to start from from an AV e
scheme that is selectively secured so
this quadratic space would be the
attribute space of the selectively
secure skin and I want to construct the
scheme that is deductively secure and in
that in a secure scheme the attribute
space will be on the rows so in my new
construction that they now want to
describe each attribute will correspond
to a single row but in fact they have
little bit more control than that
because they use a selectively secure
skin which in in which I have more
attributes than that then you can see as
a user of my skin make sense okay maybe
maybe to be so so so soon as I have this
quadratic space of some underlying skin
and now I want to go and create
respective to some X in my new scheme
but I'm now constructing so we'll go to
the role of the specific X and then I
will randomly select one column and then
I will generate the cipher text
respective to the attribute that
corresponds to this cell in the
underlying skin that I'm using can i
chime in with a couple of questions that
came
so first of all there was question about
if you can clarify what is the tank
space and like what is the space of
possible tags and the other question is
so you're talking about the EPS and the
exes and could you clarify what happens
with the message that is that is being
encrypted okay so the tech space will be
of exponential size that's the question
just I will just enlarge the attribute
space that's I'm using in their
underlying scheme so I add additional
[ __ ] to the attributes and then I
called the the suffix part the tag of
the attributes and the other question
was what happens with the message when I
increase so when I want to and sweep and
creep respective to some attribute
extent I would still encrypt the same
message but now I only changed the
attribute changes because if you recall
them in the definition of the message
tonight I provided fictional and both
with the message and their attributes
respective to which I want to increase
so dimension the message and state
saying what now the attribute would be
the real attribute they won't but in
addition some weights that described a
random town okay I hope this answer is
uh I think these questions thanks I hope
okay so in terms of correctness this
this abstraction should work because the
key should be able to provide it should
be able to decrypt all the holes in the
row except of one tag and this tag is
chosen randomly and also the the column
under which a in previous ciphertext is
also chosen randomly so the only case
for the decryption would fairly is if
is if the ciphertext by accident falls
on the punctured the childhood of the
secret key but because the tax base is
very large then this should only happen
with a negligible probability so in
terms of correctness we should be good
now the question is why does this help
us to get adopted security so let's see
so again I want to show so basically we
can think of attributes basics goes the
new attribute space X cross X X X - X
empty so the question was if we can if
we can think of the construction some
abstraction where we can we map it - yes
okay so let's see why it should be why
it should have to achieve there that's
it security so here is the idea we
assumed that the underlying skin has
selective security and recorded in
selected security we need to announce in
advance the the partitioning of the
attribute space or which attributes are
are the authorized attributes and which
attributes should be the ones under
under which it is easy to fit the
ciphertext I hear noises okay so so
let's see why why this is useful so
consider now that before the game begins
we commit to some partitioning spaces
follow
so for each we will randomly select a
column in advance so instead of doing
this during the encryption and
the key generation at the beginning of
the simulation so it shows a random
mapping it will be pseudo-random but for
now assume that it's random so for each
row which is around and now the
simulator would work as follows so every
time we're asked to generate a
ciphertext and instead of choosing a
random column we will use the column
that we already chose when the
simulation began and similarly every
time we are asked to generate the secret
gate and instead of choosing a random my
cell in which children
we will also puncture it on the
beginning of the simulation so what
happens now in this setting is that for
every given attribute or equivalently
for every row we can both simulate the
ciphertext and simulate a secret key
because every time we are asked to
simulate the secret key we only need to
simulate keys for all the attributes in
except of the punctured point and every
time we are asked to simulate the
ciphertext
we only need to simulate it on a single
code so we can do it on the and notice
here is that now we don't we don't just
the mapping randomly I mean which is it
randomly but but it's correlated for the
secret keys and the ciphertext because
we use the same point sports for the
keys and ciphertext
but the adversaries is not allowed to
ask a ciphertext and a secret key for
the same point because once he asked a
ciphertext for some attribute then he is
not allowed to worry for the secret key
that's allowed to the keys to decrypt
this attribute so the adversary cannot
notice that we are priority choose off
the cones and we use in the use the same
function points both
the secret keys and the psychotics okay
why do we need so much so many problems
okay so we this related to the previous
question about the space of tags right
the columns the space of columns is
exactly the space of tags right yes why
do we need so many times so we want the
the friction failure probability to be
negligible because if the which is the
the puncture point of the secret key
randomly and if it by accident force on
the same on the same point and so now
the question is how to actually
implement implement this abstract yeah I
put in our so then you think and by
implementing the so previously in the
pallino all this this the the
description of the of the function point
was done with the random man polynomial
and then there was there was some bound
on the number of allowed queries but now
we can actually implement it with with
paraffin then we can support and
unbounded the polynomial number of
queries so for now I will not show the
technical construction nexuses but this
is the high-level idea
yes sorry this is a secret key method
public key encryption key no no no it's
a public encryption it's a public key
encryption if I sum the underlines
selectively secure scheme are you
concerned about the child's being
repealed yes you're saying your
instantiation is based on a PRF
[Music]
yes but the paraffin only appears in the
in the security proof he does not appear
in the in the construction itself so in
the indirect construction the tags are
truly random and in the security profile
abuse the fact that the adversary is not
allowed to ask for a ciphertext and a
key for the same PO and therefore it can
use them okay so now let's see how to go
from IB to a be to have ciphertext that
can be that are targeted to some policy
let's see what the things that should be
change
so here every cipher text in the IP
every ciphertext was targeted for single
attributes which translated to a single
row but now we want to have a be e so we
want to every ciphertext to be
associated with some faction and then
for correctness the decryption the
picture mechanism that we want is that
as long as the
as the as the secret key is on any of
the degrade rows then it should be
possible to to decrypt so again if we
ignore just for this moment efficiency
issues there is a trivial way to go from
ibe to ami which is to simply generate
multiple ciphertext so assume that for
every authorized attribute we generate
the fresh ciphertext the same way we did
in in the IV so the encryption algorithm
gets us input this function f and then
he goes over all the attributes checks
whether it is authorized and if it is
authorized and he performs the previous
description which is choosing random a
talent and then generating the
ciphertext respective to this step so
again this is not efficient but if we
use this approach then we can apply
exactly the same security reduction idea
so again we will use a random mapping
only in the simulation we can use a PRF
and then whenever a secret key there was
a puncture the secret key on the on the
column that we already chose for this
before the given row and then worry when
there is this deciphered text query so
now for all the authorized rows will
generate the cipher text on the on the
pseudo random column that we already
committed to at the beginning of the
simulation and again like in the IPA
case we use the fact that the adversary
is only allowed to to query for secret
keys that are not authorized to to
decrypt the cipher text so now the the
adversary gets to see
psycho texts on multiple rows which
corresponds to seeing the PRF evaluation
on multiple inputs right because we said
that the the function point is
purification but we know the the that
the the adversary is is never allowed to
ask for a secret key just can that can
depict any of the authorized rows so he
would never get to see the same pseudo
random value for the same row twice and
therefore he cannot learn that this is
actually and not not actually true
random sample time so this is a not
efficient and I will see what the
requirements that we have in order to
actually apply this idea so the first
thing is that in in in the ciphertext we
we cannot actually provide all of those
ciphertext for all of the authorized
points because there can be exponential
than many so so we need so we need to
somehow have such thing description of
the ciphertext and they should look
pseudo-random because we said that the
before we apply the efficiency tweak we
wanted the tags to be truly meant so now
we have exponentially many ciphertext
and they should correspond to two random
tags so we must use something that is
random and then we have the following
requirements so we need that the
secretary on those puncture points that
we committed to it the simulation and
and we need to have the property that
even
when the adversary gets to see the
punctured points on some rows which
corresponds to asking for secret keys
then even given that still the types of
ciphertext I think I think there was a
question of why do you need it to be a
pseudo-random function rather than just
random values they're sampled on the fly
so where do you use the fact that it
actually is a PRF and has a 16
description I think that was the
question I hope I understood correctly
okay so I provided a cipher text
multiple cipher texts of the underlying
scheme where each of them corresponds to
a different authorized attributes and
the random child but now the number of
authorized attributes can be
exponentially large
so and I don't want my final ciphertext
to be exponentially large so I need to
provide something that is succinct but
it should correspond to exponentially
many cipher texts for each of them in
particular encodes this random value so
I need to have exponential number of
values that's not random so that
immediately translates to a PRF that way
they must be pseudo-random because they
need to describe them succinctly okay so
so we have those two requirements where
on one hand
who want to have 16 on the other hand 16
description to look super random even
given access to other points because we
need to answer the secret keys the
secret key queries and to provide the
punctured points for for the secret keys
so we actually we there's no way to use
a standard PRF for that because we need
we need to provide a peer evaluation on
multiple points simultaneously without
giving each of them independently so for
this we exactly have the constraint
period so what is the constraint PRF it
is somewhat similar flavor to attribute
based encryption so in standard PRF if
you don't have the secret seeds than all
of the peer evaluations look
pseudo-random to you and if you have the
parents it and you can compute the PRF
on all possible inputs in a constraint
parents then there is the master C which
again can compute the PRF on all
possible inputs with a little in
addition it is possible to use this
master C then to generate constraint
seeds so I constraints it will be
associated with some that it is possible
to compute the PRF value using a
constraints in for us only if f of X is
allowed only if f of X except this input
X so that would be did the PRF value
using the master seed and that would be
the pair of value using the constraints
in for F and a should be equal condition
than f of X equals 1 and if f of X
equals 0 then the value of the PRF
should look random even given the
constraints it for it
so it gives you exact permissions to
only the computer PRF on on on some
inputs while guaranteeing that the
security remains some of the other
equals so actually in our context we
only need the constraint PRF that that
that is secure given a single constraint
is there is question if I understand
correctly
unlike the ibe case here the PRF is used
even in the construction am i right yes
[Music]
okay so now let's see how to use the
constraint in the construction so
looking back again in to the high level
now we want to use the constraint graph
in order to to have the efficiency
properties so instead of implementing
the the punctured points with standard
period who now implement them with the
constraint period so we represent this
punctured space by a PLC and then every
time we want to puncture a secret kid
and we use the evaluation of the PRF on
the given attribute so it should be the
role and then you want to determine the
corresponding column we compute the PRF
and now when we want to to generate to
simulate a ciphertext then in order to
give this something description of the
the evaluation of the paraffin on
multiple rows we can simply give a
constraint set for for the same function
f so it exactly corresponds to learning
the tags only for the rows that are
authorized by F while guaranteeing that
the tags of all the other rows are still
pseudo-random so that's what happens in
the
in the security booth but now we need to
go back to the to the real construction
and change it in a way that it will
still be indistinguishable from the
simulation so we said that in the
simulation the ciphertext is associated
with a constraint see it which
corresponds to the real seed that we
chose at the beginning of the simulation
so now we've in the real construction
that again the ciphertext will be
associated with some with some
constraints it but in the real scheme we
we don't have the de punctured space we
first a sample a random AC in Sigma
Prime and then we use it to compute the
constraint seed for F so that would be
Sigma prime sub F and then we use the
seed in order to succinctly describe of
the pseudo-random tags of the ciphertext
so this process of first sampling a
fresh random seed corresponds to the
process of sampling random tag for the
ciphertext so we sample this random seed
and then the constraints it for F and in
that way will later be indistinguishable
the simulated ciphertext
so that should solve both of our
requirements because we have the
guarantee that they constrain the see
that allows to compute of the of the
tags of the authorized attributes but
anything
[Music]
[Music]
so so now let's really see how how to
instantiate those ideas so I will give a
brief overview of the BG g plus
selectively a beanie construction but it
will respond to fix the core tech
discussed in there in the previous stuff
but that's Percy public key encryption
so we have the W exception which briefly
says that given a public matrix a and
then this instance which is s times a
person and then that should be
indistinguishable from a and a random
vector u so the way to use that's in the
policy okay so that should be
indistinguishable from a random vector
but then it is also possible to generate
a with some secret trapdoor for this I
don't so then given this data it should
be easy to distinguish between those two
cases so the way to use the and then the
secret key would be the trapdoor for the
matrix a and then in order to generate a
ciphertext then the the randomness the
encryption would be fresh s and E and
then the pseudo randomness of this value
will be used to encrypt the message I
omitted the message itself from the
description here but once this y-you
looks random we can use it to encrypt
the message and
and then given the trapdoor it should be
easy to to to distinguish the ciphertext
we informant and therefore the message
should be hard so now
[Music]
so again the public key is so matrix a
and then the master secret key now would
be in would be accept all for this
matrix a you know there are three
additional algorithms so they correspond
to the computation of those short age
mattresses that discussed in the
previous hour so there would be so there
would be in algorithm two takes and
matrix a and somebody eats and outputs a
matrix a sub X additionally there will
be an algorithm detects the same matrix
a and some function f and outputs the
matrix that we did not a sub F and why
are those are interesting because they
also have this additional relation
between them so there is an evaluation
algorithm that can take an LW instance
respective to the public matrix a sub X
and also a function X and it can
evaluate the the function f over this LW
instance in such a way that will get an
lwe instance respective to the matrix a
sub F and also the value of the
evaluation of the generic scheme and
seen before so that's what I'm aiming
for but right now I'm a giving an
overview of the selectively secure a B
that will be used later
so that's a previous one okay so now
given those s we algorithms then
whenever we want to generate the that's
a question so you see I should think of
both limits functions I guess when you
write a sub X mmm then coding would be
different so there's some comments that
Shafi that you're not coming across in
terms of volume okay sorry
maybe I shouldn't ask questions you just
type in I guess my question is this
notation a sub X I see did I think
there's an overloading of notation
because they use the same thing to
denote different things yes yes that
would be different a different kind of
matrix but I use use this in order to
emphasize that they are both public keys
let me this ho take let me just connect
to the previous talk it's a axis what's
a 1 minus X 1 G a 2 minus X 2 G yeah and
it's a same else that's fine with them
don't worry a F is the same as from
before about we write multiplication by
the each stop at X matrix but this is no
a sub F identifying immense about F is
multiplying by
X but since we have about five minutes
until the end of the talk let's try to
let Rotom finish with what you wanted to
cover and then we can have additional
discussions okay so then given the sound
origins then when we want to generate
[Music]
okay so one thing they mention is that
in this context we consider a dual
notion where the ciphertext is
respective to X and then the decryption
policy is respective to X but you can
always use Universal circuits to
exchange but so in this context we
assume that the cipher text is
respective to X then we can generate a
cipher text simply as an lwe instance
respective to the matrix a sub X and
then we want to generate the constraint
key for the policy then we would provide
a trapdoor for them and of course we
need to have this additional property of
the encode F function that if we have
the trapdoor for the a that would begin
with then we can also compute the
trapdoor for this and so the cipher text
would be respective to ax and then in
order to decrypt we use this evaluation
algorithm so this evaluation and Whitin
takes the ciphertext suspected to two
today we takes and it evaluates F of it
and then on it and then we get nlw
instance respective to AF plus something
that denotes whether we should defeat or
not and then using the trapdoor for a
sub F we can we we can get rid of the of
the parts that make the depiction hard
and I'm I'm I don't want to get more
details right now but this is in high
level of the PG + 14
construction okay so now how how the
selected security single net simulator
works there so we get an LW instance
which corresponds to some
computationally hard problem that the
simulator should show the reduction to
and in addition because we're in the
selective setting then we get in advance
the subutex so now here is we need to
provide the ciphertext and LW instance
respective to a civics and we also know
in advance what what X is going to be so
instead of choosing a random matrix a is
the path you will generate the matrix in
such a way that if we compute and code
the X of eight for the given X that you
already know then we will end up with
the matrix B that we got is the
challenge so in that way we we can
provide adversarial w/e challenge
respectively to be where when it's
queries foreign and lovely challenge
perspective to a sub X because that
would be the same matrix okay so now
let's see how to use all of that in
order to implement the target technique
with the constraint PRF so as we saw
earlier I said when we want to encrypt a
message we need to first sample a random
seed Sigma Prime and then computes the
constraint PRF the constraint key for it
their respective to F so for that part
this is what we do with sample
constraint key constraint PRF key for
the function f and then we use the HT
plus 14 friction so a nice property of
the PDG plus key is that this if
an algorithm it was gained by gates so
we can actually do some part of the
computation and then stop there and
later with more gates of this
computation so we would look at the
partial evaluation of of the function
the Texas input a mustard seed of a PRF
and computes the constraining algorithm
algorithm that that has the policy
effort and it takes a master seed and
outputs the constraint so then we
generated vdg plus 14 ciphertext
respective to this function and to the
supposedly result value which is the
constraint see that we chose randomly
but the reason that this is useful is
because later in the in the simulation
we always begin with the same seed and
then in order to simulate to simulate
the circuit X for any F that all we have
to do G evaluation of the constraining
algorithm and we will always end up with
the bgg ciphertext respective to this
algorithm which results in the
corresponding constraint key for the
same way now in order to generate a key
for some attribute X so as in the
abstract description we first choose a
random tag you know we want to have the
property that you can only decrypt if if
if if this X is authorized by the cipher
text policy and the tag and the tag of
the secret key is different than the the
tag of the cipher text so we explicitly
use these functions of this function
takes the constraint seed that is that
appears in should appear in the cipher
text so that's what this function would
take an input and then evaluate the PRF
constraints it on the on the attributes
and it's a
to decrypt as long as the resulting tag
does not for the 20 punctured point of
the secret key or in other words as long
as this evaluation does not equal then
the random tag that we chose there's a
question let's not take questions now
let's not take questions now but rather
in the end address then you open any
unanswered questions if we have time
okay sure okay so now what we want to do
so we use the Selective security but you
know instead of announcing the attribute
so now we only need to announce this
seed the single succeed that we choose
which corresponds to of the constraint
of the punctured tanks and so now we
have a selective sighs ridiculous
ciphertext respective to the same and
whenever we are worried for a ciphertext
all we have to do is to evaluate the
constraint function required to provide
with the adversary and let's say that I
want to say is that actually for this
thing to work
we need the constraint P I have the
constraint PRF to have some special
properties so I said that the PDG plus
evaluation is done gate by gate and in
the encryption we use constraining in
the constraint algorithm and in the key
generation we use directly the the
purush valuation so what we need from
the constraint is to help it is very
special structural property is that that
those two different look exactly the
same if we look at them as a sequence of
gate so the first algorithm is that
winner takes a master seed and computes
the PRF in the second algorithm is the
algorithm that takes a master seed first
computes the constraint key for some s
and then use this constraints
compute the PRF on some input X so but
the correctness of the constraint Parris
the output of those algorithms should
always be the same but our environment
is stronger we require that actually the
evaluation itself OBE would be the same
and this is why we only we can only do
that for the TCF because for now we only
have the constraint purif for this
function family that satisfies this
strong performance so can answer all
right first of all thanks for them
let's let's take you can look at the QA
thank you there's questions that you
prefer to address in front of everybody
and if not you can answer you can still
dress the Q&A during the break via text
is there a way to leave this
construction to a functional encryption
scheme for some family of functions we
can take that Oh fine answer another
generic question if there is time and
hope to improve efficiency and what
parts to run long kids for that so it
depends on the what kind of efficiency
improvements you want to have I think
the the bottleneck at this point is the
efficiency limitations of the wg+ 14
because other than that the scheme
itself pretty similar so yeah all right
thanks thanks Alton let's let's all
think so think all them again those of
us who can